and so you've said previously that you
wanted to remake the film in order to
tell the story from a woman's point of
view and I'm fascinated that you were
filming it whilst all the hoo-ha around
the u.s. election was going on what was
it like filming during that time yeah
when we started working this project I
wasn't thinking about that I was just
thinking about the story and of course
at the heart of it it's about power
between men and women at that story and
then the election was happening when we
were filming and it was it was just a
strange environment and so you know in
the air this kind of will you know that
topic of male and female and power and
but if the power really switches
incredibly suddenly throughout the film
you really feel that the women are on
top and then suddenly something will
happen it's really interesting to see
how you can feel incredibly confident
and then have the rug taken away yeah I
thought I was fascinated with that being
at the heart of the story and I feel
like in any relationship or watching the
story you can you can relate of course
not in such a melodramatic way but that
was the fun of looking at something that
we can all relate to but that in a
really heightened way you also of course
won Best Director at can and
congratulations all done it did to an
outsider almost feel as though your
achievement was overshadowed by the fact
that it been so long since a woman had
won that prize how did that feel
yeah I was really surprised when I
learned the history when they said the
woman hadn't wanted since the early
sixties so I was proud a surprise and
it's sad that there hadn't been more
women in that field but um I was proud
to win it and also I just felt so much
happiness and support from so many women
that I felt shared and that with me so
it was that was a great feeling it
certainly feels like there are a lot of
really strong more also more mainstream
films going out to bigger audiences
coming from female directors at the
moment are there any other any women
directors that have really struck you I
mean I grew up with Jane Campion being a
huge role model for me and I had a home
door winner still yeah yeah yeah it's
hard to believe that history but um but
I still you know I'm excited that Wonder
Woman's a big head and that you know it
seems like the business people are
realizing that that's a real market that
it's worth investing in
field of thought 50% popular disaster
the other thing I'm staggered buys it
took patty Jenkins 14 years since
monster since bringing para Charlize
Theron yes I have inhalation on a little
that long to Best Actress Oscar for her
to get another film and it's been so
fantastically successful well would you
ever be tempted to do a superhero film I
have never thought about it but I
remember a couple years ago saying
where's Wonder Woman who's going to do
that and so I'm happy that anti Jenkins
made it and did such a great job
what do you thinkin DC or marvel Coppola
film would look like I never I can't
imagine my sensibility translating into
that world but who knows
thank you so much thank you